as we begin with new information today
in the search for an interim
superintendent to lead the clark county
school district
the school board trustees plan to
discuss this issue this week after dr
jesus jarrow was voted out by the board
late last week i should say joe mueller
is live outside ccsd headquarters with
what we know about the timeline joe
christian the trustees will discuss who
will be the interim superintendent this
thursday the president linda cavazo just
tweeted out about this just a short time
ago meanwhile parents still have a lot
of questions about what happened
with dr jesus jarrah voted out he is
expected to leave his position while
getting paid out his contract that was
through 2023 he is expected to leave
with nearly half a million dollars pta
president rebecca garcia says this is a
lot of money for the district to just
pay out she says it is concerning and
parents have questions that have yet to
be answered like why jarrah was voted
out she worries about who will want to
work for the school board obviously
anybody stepping into this role
will be able to watch our school board
meetings and we'll be able to see the
news coverage
and if it is a local candidate
they will be well aware of the
challenges that exist she says parents
deserve to know more about what exactly
happened she says transparency needs to
happen with this process moving
forward anjara is expected to remain
superintendent later this month that
meeting on the interim role will happen
this thursday evening reporting live
outside of ccsd headquarters joe mullen
live local now